the results of Tuesday's elections still
sinking in yeah it's hard to think about
anything else yeah yeah it's been the
big story everyone talking about a lot
of people are still some are shocked
some are disappointed at the outcome but
obviously not everyone is upset yeah
there's a good half the country that's
feeling good about it in fact we have a
couple of Trump supporters in our
audience tonight they're with us right
now
hey you guys you're candidate one you
guys must be pretty happy happy what the
hell is that supposed to mean okay I
mean you voted I'm sorry you voted for
Donald Trump and then he won no I mean
what is happy mean yeah we've been angry
at the system for so long it's all we
know our anger has been the one thing
that we had in common yeah we even
finished each other's sentences check it
out
[Applause]
we're romantic yeah
gets a lot of Trump supporters were
united in their anger though huh yeah
and these new feelings are freaking us
out when I woke up Wednesday morning I
didn't even feel like posting death
threats on Twitter and I saw a copy of
the New York Times and I didn't even
spit on it
what am I supposed to do with all this
spit today I saw a guy drinking a latte
and I didn't even have the energy to
slap it out of his hands what is
happening to me okay I'll tell you
what's happening to you that's called
happiness oh my god Conan look what the
hell is that thing on my wife's face no
no calm down
that's a smile oh no now I got it too
it's spreading quick gonna tell a joke
or take your shirt off okay I'm sorry
I'm really sorry I'm gonna give them the
gas give the gas Billy
[Applause]
[Music]
did you just kill two more PPI yeah it's
for the best yes it's catches tonight by
killing people and then watching to see
how long the actors gonna hold it I knew
once you had that poison gas installed
all right we're gonna take a little
break me come back there very good I
gotta say thank you
you